X 17. Yeah, it's been around for a while. I think if it's around.
Rather.
I think couple of, uh,
2016 was the first time I came across this work done by
these nuclear physicists in Hungary. They were looking at,
um, beryllium the, the nucleus of beryllium,
that's got four protons and four neutrons in it.
You can excite this nucleus. We know with atoms and electrons, right?
If you excite the electrons in an atom,
they raise up an energy level and then they don't want to stay there.
We're all lazy, really, right.
We want to go back to what we call our ground States and that's how we produce
light. And so we're all familiar with the consequences of that. But in fact,
you can do it with a nucleus as well.
What they do is they create an excited beryllium nucleus by
they ha they start with a lithium nucleus,
and then they attach a proton to it. So a very specific energy.
So here's my lithium nucleus and incomes, a proton with a very specific energy.
It then forms a beryllium nucleus, which is already as an excited state.
So the handout excited state is compared to its natural ground state.
It doesn't want to stay like this. Right?
And so what actually usually happens is it just disintegrates again,
it just goes back to the proton, goes out and elect with the lithium,
but every now and again,
what actually happens is as it drops back down to its ground state,
is it emits a virtual photon and that virtual photon just
goes and disappears off on you then every now and again,
even less likely is the, is that it admits the photon.
And then the photon itself creates a pair of electron,
an electron positron pair and E plus B minus pair.
Now what usually happens is in those situations,
the photons coming out. And so the, the two particles,
the electrons and positrons pair, they're very light particles.
So when they're created, they're almost colinear with, with the outgoing photon.
So photons coming out towards you,
Brady and then the electron positron pair of created. And,
and so the angle between them,
this is the crucial thing is usually rent remains small.
And so as the angle increases the number of electron positron pairs that
come out at larger and larger angles decreases because it doesn't want to do it.
It wants to create come out because of conservation of momentum,
easier for it to come out.
Straightforward.
People noticed was that, um,
at an angle of about 140 degrees. So let's see, this is zero,
uh, is that 90? And so 140, I mean, is, is out here.
They found a bump. They found an increase in the number of,
uh, electron positron pairs out. And we know from our Higgs there,
that if you've got an increase in number of events,
then some it's a potential sign that something's funny going on,
that you would normally have expected this number coming out as you increase the
angle, just to drop off on the tonically,
but it suddenly it went up what could be causing this
one interpretation is it's,
it's a particle that's being produced that then declares itself into the E
plus C minus. And this is the X particle. And when they work out,
given the angle that the E plus C minus pair come out 140
degrees, you can work out what the corresponding mass of the particle must be.
And it's 17 million electron volts, 17 MEV.
And that's where the X 17 comes from. It's the, it's the,
the mass of this particle incomes.
The initial proton comes out in, from outside. The lithium hits the lithium,
converts it into a beryllium nucleus,
which has now got four protons and neutrons by fine tuning,
the incoming proton energy.
You can raise the energy level of this nuclei of the beryllium to
actually, I think is 18.16 MEV million electron volts.
And that's an excited static. It is not the ground state.
It then declares as it declares rather than creating the photon,
which then creates the electron positron pair.
It creates this X particles.
So that's when the X 17 happens during the,
during the relaxation of the excited.
It creates this, but it's a massive particle. So it's coming out now with,
with relatively low momentum. That then means that when it,
when it decays to when it does it split, it,
does it split create the electron positron pair.
There can come out to a large angle, uh, whereas a photon couldn't.
Cause if I was a high momentum,
it's going to then want to go directly into the policy minus in the same
direction.
So because the X 17 is so sluggish and has less momentum,
it creates this ability to do a wider angle. I don't know.
Anglia split and it, and so that was the interpretation and there,
they wrote this up. It didn't do a lot for Lee for awhile for a few months.
It sort of led there. But I remember reading a paper by, um,
Jonathan Fang and his collaborators Irvine,
where they were looking at this experiment and trying to interpret this
results in terms of some model. And so it was then that I,
I remember reading it and thinking, in order to explain this result,
they are having to do something some twists and turns in the particle physics
beyond what you would normally expect from the standard model of particle
physics in order to get these it's a,
this X particle is a Bosun, it's got spin one,
and there have been experiments looking for these particles.
[inaudible] experiment is one at CERN,
which had been looking for virtual bows zones like these and hadn't found any.
And in fact,
it would natively have ruled out this experiment of the beryllium from their own
results.
And in order to sort of make sure the two were compatible Fang and
collaborators realized that one way of doing it would be to effectively change
some of the interactions that the protons were having with this X
particle such that it would be access.
It would be allowed for the beryllium experiment to do what it was doing,
but it would account for the fact that the [inaudible] experiment was not
seeing anything it's generated a lot of interest. I mean,
I think there's like 140 papers have been written,
citing this original work, but it was back in 2016.
I think the thing that has caused the renewed interest,
the same group in hungry produced new results this time not
using beryllium, but using a helium nucleus,
they did the same sorts of experiments. And they found that once again, there,
there was a bump when they were looking at the,
the creation of the electron positron pear, they found a bump,
not 140 degrees, which was the result for the beryllium, but, uh,
I think 115 degrees. And when they work,
then work backwards and took into account the fact that this was a helium
nucleus and not a beryllium nucleus,
they once again found that the corresponding mass of the particle,
that if you understood it as from the decay of a particle was I think
it's 16.7 million electron volts, again,
comparable to what they had before. That sounds like a smoking gun.
It does sound like a smoking gun it's quite intriguing, but in the meantime,
there have been the initial results, um, that they,
they obtained in 2016 has of course,
got people thinking about this. And the,
the experimentalists at CERN have been, there's a,
an experiment called I think it's an S 64,
which published its results in 2006, 2018.
So about a year ago when they went looking for the original
X particle, right, they went looking for, uh, for, uh, uh, gauged Bozon,
which had a massive about 16.7 million electron volts.
And the way they did it was they used the super protons synchrotron
Collider at CERN.
They had a beam of electrons of about a hundred GV
giga electron volts. They collided it into a target.
So it's called a beam dump that collided it into a target because if this
particle was there,
what would happen is that electrons that were being stopped as it hit,
the target could interact with actually [inaudible] said
[inaudible] and the targets,
and they in principle could produce this X particle.
And then the X particle bean with its interactions could actually leave the
beam dump.
And it would then decay further down the chain and in a
set of detectors creating the plus minus pair.
And so what they were looking for with these two sort of almost simultaneous
events, not quite simultaneous where the beam dump loses an amount of energy,
but that same amount of energy is found further down the line.
And the interpretation would be the electron had, as it hit,
the Zed Bozon would have created this particle,
which then moved out from the beam dump further down into the depths detection
decade. And they didn't see it. They saw no evidence of it.
And so that has allowed them to rule out regions of the parameter
space that the original paper was was exploring.
But this new results,
which is with the helium sort of is it sounds like a smoking gun
in some ways it is because it's a new nuclei, but what's,
it's really,
really crying out for is another experiment along the same lines as the
beryllium one, but done by a different team. Right?
Why did we, why did people so readily.
Accepted the Higgs? Well, I think there were two major reasons.
One was mathematically.
It was expected to be in the ballpark where it was found.
That's why they built the LHC with the energy they did on the size of did.
So the mathematics of the standard model and beyond the standard model had
suggested there should be something there.
And then two detectors totally separate detectors found it
effectively, simultaneously. They were finding evidence for the Higgs.
That's the CMS detector in Atlas.
We're finding it simultaneously in this case,
there's one experiment and is found it once. It's,
there's a bit of a track record where they have found events before that have,
that have disappeared,
found evidence for these bosoms of different masses that have disappeared.
They're arguing this as, uh, a stronger result,
but they found it for beryllium. And now for helium, that that's positive.
But what it's really requiring is another experiment along those lines to come
along and say yes, and confirm it.
Have other teams try to,
are there other teams around the world who've done similar experiments and said,
we haven't found that bump at those angles.
Not aware of other experiments,
doing exactly what the brilliant Hungarian guys are doing,
because they're doing a proper nuclear physics experiment.
And so this is this interesting interface between nuclear physics,
natural particle physics, that the, the experience that I'm aware of, uh,
testing this, uh, particle physics experiments,
colliding electrons that are high energy into a beam dump and looking
for different types of detectors, looking for dark matter detectors. I mean,
one of the exciting things about this result,
if it was to hold is that there are dark matter
models, which would have a particle of around 10,
20 million electron volts.
These light particles could be there. And, and these,
there are models where there are these vector. Bosons
when I talked about the why, why did we believe the Higgs? I said, well,
because the standard model was suggesting and beyond the sesh suggesting sh
it should be there. It was in the mathematics.
One of the things that has had they've had to do in this particular case from
the theoretical standpoint is you we've had to do some quite
severe twists and turns to the particle physics to make sure we can
accommodate this result in terms of a particle whilst also accepting
[inaudible], didn't find it at CERN. It's not an easy fit. It's not an easy fit.
And in fact, you've basically had to introduce a new charge that, that,
that accounts for why this X particle doesn't interact with the proton,
like it would with the electron. And in fact, it's,
it's called proto phobic. It doesn't want to interact with the proton.
It will happily now interact with the neutron, but not with the proton.
And that's unusual photons normally will interact with the, with the,
with the proton and you're forcing this to do it.
And so you'd need to look for examples, why this is not happening.
Is there another logical explanation doing the rounds?
Are there other physicists who are saying, Oh, no,
I can explain those bumps at those angles. It could just be, you know, XYZ ed.
I think that if you want it to be, so one possibility is, as I said,
if it's one possibility, that's a mistake. Oh yeah. So we should,
should point that out. Of course, right? That, um, there,
that's another reason why you need to do this experiment with another group
that, that, or maybe they've got their systematics wrong, perhaps this bumpers.
I mean, the, the,
the words you hear is this is like a seven Sigma detection or seven Sigma means
it's one, one chance in a hundred billion. That it's a random event.
I mean that, so,
but if you've missed some big systematic that that could all go away,
I'm not aware of any sort of realistic accepted
particle physics explanations as to what this is other than people coming in
with this idea of a particle or the possibility that it's,
it's actually not there at all.
We've just got to go and revisit the systematics of the experiment.
If we imagine the X 17 particle is legit, it is real, right.
Yeah. What can you tell me about it? Can you give me an IC,
can you give me an idea on it's like how big that is and what charge it is?
Yeah.
So it's light. So, and an electron, which we,
we actually tend to think of it as being almost massless right. Is half an MEV.
So this 34 times the massive,
the electron the proton is roughly a thousand MEV,
but th th you've you've as usual, you've come up with a key question,
which, which is that, um,
it's not particularly the pro the particle that's important here. And that,
why is that the particle in, in, in, in particle physics is,
is symptomatic of the existence of something else it's symptomatic of the
existence of a, of a constant field.
So when we think of the photon and particle physics, the associated fields,
the electromagnetic field, when we think of the, um, uh,
the Higgs particle,
that was discovered why people were so excited was the existence of the Hicks
field and what the particles are.
And excitations of those fields, very strong excitations,
the existence of a field means that there's a force between there's an
interaction between particles.
And so what you are finding here is if this particle really exists,
there's an associated X field exists, and we have a fifth force.
And the mass of this field is such that this could be a long range, fifth force.
And then you've got all sorts of interesting possibilities coming in about why
we're not detected it. What are,
what are its subsequent properties and what other influences could it have on
the, on forces on nature?
We're always looking for fifth forces. I mean, well,
some people would say it's a sixth force. Let me, which said,
there's electromagnetism, there's the weak interactions,
the strong interactions, gravity,
the discovery of the Higgs is regarded as some,
as providing us with another interaction,
which is the interaction of the Higgs field with particles. And,
but this new interaction is,
has not been detected before if it's there and it could
open the, you know,
there is many searches on for examples of either of these long range
interactions with regard to the dark energy driving the acceleration of the
universe with all, with regards to the presence of the particles themselves,
is that matter candidates,
that there is a big push for these light dark matter candidates at the moment,
because we're not,
we haven't seen any evidence of supersymmetry in the large Hadron Collider,
which is usually associated with the existence of wimps.
So the wimp dark matter candidate hasn't shown up yet.
And so people are naturally beginning to sort of think, well,
perhaps we should need to look further a field could X 17 be dark matter. Well,
there's one possibility that are that matter candidates that are in that regime
in terms of their mass range. Now, I,
I don't know enough about the interaction cross section of this acts,
17 particle with other particles.
The people have looked in are looking in this mass range with these were called
directed detectors, that direct dark matter detectors.
And they haven't seen anything,
but whether or not that in its own right yet says anything about these acts 17
remains to be seen.
X 17 has no charge. Like it's not negative,
like an electron or positive like proton.
Um, no, I don't think so because it declares producing an any plus minus overall
electric charges.
If you told me Brady go and find me an electron, I think I know where to look.
You know, if you separately find me a proton or a neutron,
I know where you said, find me a photon.
They're quite easy to find where are the X seventeens if they exist?
Where are they?
So the, the, if the, if they're there and that they're there, they're there.
Um, it turns out that they're not in that decay of the beryllium, for example,
where remember what I said,
beryllium naturally just to care's back to the lithium. It just breaks up again.
There's then, then the next level of decay is via these virtual photons,
which then themselves, the decay ins that you plus the minors,
one in a million of them roughly would be the production of the X.
But that's a rare event. That's delusion.
So you're going to have to work hard. Right. You're going to say.
So right now there's no X seventeens. If they exist right now,
there's no exceptions in you. Yeah.
Um, I don't, that's a good question. Um, I don't think I'm any, well,
I often am quite excited and I do get excited. I don't know.
I think of an individual, uh, Healy. I mean,
I've got helium in me and I don't think, and I must have some beryllium in me,
I guess, too. I don't think it's that,
that excited energy state that indicates if it does, by the way,
it's pretty hard to find.
I think their lifetime is around 10 to the minus 12 seconds.
So it could have found them that they just disappeared.
So if particles are excitations of a field,
including electrons and protons and things like that,
how come electrons and protons are so abundant in this room
and so long lived. And yet this X 17,
which is heavier than an electron and lighter than a proton,
doesn't have this ability to manifest itself and then hang around.
So that's, that's a, that's a tough question.
But so the electron is the,
so the electromagnetic field is pervading this room and the electrons would be
associated with, well,
the photons would be associated with excitations of that as would be the
electrons, which are electromagnetic interactions.
The protons are a bit more unusual that the majority of the mass of the proton
is not in the quarks and the majority of the mass of the proton. I mean, if you,
if you add up the mass of the quarks, each quark is as a rest massive about,
um, three MEV. So their total mass is about 10 MEV.
And I've just said the massive a proton is a thousand MEV.
So the majority of the massive process is actually in the binding energy of the,
of the, of the quarks of the glue-ons sorry,
that that are propagating around it all the,
so it's not quite as straightforward as sort of turning on the quarks and same
day as your prototype. So, but so I think it's it's,
but it is a case of that, that the,
the relative of excitation in the field is the thing that determines the
underlying, um, uh, massive these objects.
But the proton itself is this combination of the quarks and the glue-ons,
which makes it a bit less clear, how are you going to generate them?
So the X 17 field.
That exists is one that just doesn't get excited very often in our world.
I guess. That's true. I mean, it seems to be the product of the decay of, uh,
an, uh,
more excited uh beryllium but you've got me thinking I'm not quite sure because
it's, it doesn't require a huge amount of energy.
These are not massive energy scales compared to what you, what you get.
But I think that the issue is,
is it's not just that it does depend on the interaction, these,
the ax 17 particles have, what,
what type of interactions it has with the other force, other matter particles.
And we've seen that in order to explain its existence,
we have to already do something rather unusual.
We have to make that interaction one that's proton, proton,
or phobic in order, which means that it's not interacting,
like the usual particles are interacting.
So that could have an impact on how likely it is to be formed out of some
excitation of the field. Are you an X,
17 skeptic, or I still remain a little bit of an acceptance in skeptic.
Yeah, I think, um, it does require, um, a,
it requires more particle physics explanation for why it's might be
there in, in, uh, in a coherent framework and,
and be above all.
It needs more experimental evidence coming from a similar type of
experiment to verify whether the bump that they're seeing is actual,
real or not.
It's absorbed in the air.
So to measure the x-ray absorption of our compound,
which is sensitive to the air,
we need to be able to remove the air and in case it,
so we use beryllium to make a magic box around our sample that the x-rays can
come into.